escape room stuff what what is what
could that be what is an escape room we
did one yeah
per video yeah so with your eyes peeled
for that we didn't do too well so we
blew it up the escape room yeah we just
all evidence yeah
no one gets to do it yeah sour losers
you know it actually would be would have
been really good if we lost and we just
started tearing it apart yeah yeah pure
rage
rage quitting an escape room yeah it has
to have happened it has to have for sure
because the first one that we did we got
really close to not making it yeah and
in the last five minutes they play
like this music that's like intense it's
supposed to like make you feel like oh
[__] yeah but it was really distracting
it was and I can imagine it was also
like stressful yeah
I can imagine people are like you know
four and a half minutes into that music
they're like let's just [__] just
kick through the door yeah or
they lose it's like oh
you just made just if you had one more
minute you just missed it just raged
like if you play the [__] music bro
yeah yeah clear comms
clear comms
you don't [__] go in a game and just
start playing music
so it was actually really fun though I
had a blast yeah I wasn't really
expecting to
yeah because I also was like you know
sometimes
when you're shooting it's not like you
go in expecting fun because you it's
like shoot yeah like you have to like be
on and yeah
like the cooking ones are always like a
little bit stressful they are fun but
the escape room was like we legitimately
just went and tried to solve it yeah
so it was just fun yeah I had a blast
yeah Cody
Cody wasn't ready for how
dialed the [__] in I was yeah cause I
also thought that it was gonna be like a
classic shoot where we're gonna like try
and make jokes along the way and stuff
like that like it's like action and we
like start rolling and I was like all
right all right so we have these symbols
over here and they coincide with these
and I'm like and I'm trying to be a
[__] yeah for the first 30 seconds I
was like yeah I don't really know how to
get and then I was like okay so what are
these symbols mean and then I get into
it
one of these come out uh next month
probably about a month from now oh a
month from now okay we can yeah we can
temper it but yeah anyway so I was
saying
I've been in a relationship with you now
for for five years and I just know your
social battery
I know how you get
so
I'm just throwing it out there that
knowing you you may get there you might
see the cars go one time and you'll be
like I saw it yeah
and there's how 65 more laps yeah yeah
[Music]
that is true and then and then and then
20 minutes in Cody's like
why wouldn't they let me bring my Kindle
reader in here
so yeah dude [__] people are making
fun of me for reading a Kindle on set
it's ever rid of a book
have you heard of a book Jesse my
assistant was like what are you reading
and I was like a Kindle and she's like
why would she be reading a Kindle I'm
like shouldn't wait this is backwards
like I'm the old one should I not be why
are you making fun of me for using
digital versions of books has it
reverted now you dude you got lit up by
your own people I know
and then those are [__] awesome are
they not awesome except when they power
down
they did mine ran out of battery yeah
the Cody's ran out of battery 15 minutes
in and then and then Jesse goes
you know it always stays on a book
we were joking about how she's gonna
have to drag around a [__] uh just a
rolly backpack a suitcase of books and
then Cody goes no no
on your back yeah and then so she has to
yeah and like half of them are textbooks
just in case I want to learn something
yeah just a little math yeah how do I
find X again yeah I can't remember can
you crack open that can you find that
chapter please
you know what I really feel like doing
right now what's the log of that again
oh man
you know what I'm feeling right now uh
geometric proof
oh I love proofs yeah
damn I just got visceral flashbacks to
high school seriously of pulling those
like come feeling Pages those pages were
sticky they weren't like paper class was
this well my teacher said I was upset
I had a special book
ah
that's a bummer yeah
yeah
no um no the like textbooks it's not
like paper you know it's not like yeah I
know you're talking about it's got that
gloss to it you know
I just got a nasty flashback of
flipping those to okay chapter seven
lesson two exercise one yep
you ever get bad dreams that you're
still in school yeah yeah do you what's
the most recent one you had no I don't
get them I'm just wondering if you yeah
no I had because I I know people do so I
just because I graduated
you know I've told this like I had the I
had like the four classes left and I
took them
my credits my entire degree was about to
expire if I didn't just finish it
and I still have nightmares that I'm in
those classes oh yeah and that I failed
one yeah and so I have to go back for
one more semester
[__] me up yeah that's a nightmare and
then it's like I've had enough of those
where
now I have days where I think my diploma
isn't real or my whatever my degree
whatever the [__] that's why I gave it
to you you know you know you need one
like you'd get fired from here if you
don't have one that's a requirement
we require yeah we do am I shit's real
he's so funny we pull up one day it's
like where's the mall oh he you didn't
hear he got fired yeah he
um he has a fraudulent uh background
check oh bummer
weird yeah all right well let's get into
it
it's a lot more talking
with one person
uh bro this is my college actually this
is we should do
what whether old people in your college
yes really oh yeah I had a
communications class with a lady
uh I'm not exaggerating probably in her
mid 70s hmm
never finished College the whole
classroom
really
like she used to like speak out in class
damn and she's like I have a question
about the internet yeah yeah
you're like it's too late yeah
I'm sorry yeah it's never too late
but it's too late thinking about it now
of a person oh my god dude a seven year
old being like I'm gonna go back and get
my degree and then all their
everything yeah dude just yo gay son
thought daughter
you're old enough which one do you have
we should do Cody and Noel do semester
oh we just do an entire semester of
classes
online we don't have to go in and do
them but we have to pass
and tired glasses
I'm really excited about this yeah now
I'm really into this
we could bring the bad dreams to life
no
okay I think it'd be fun dude did I I
like learning so
I'd go take a class on something
I just yeah it has to be like a
something interesting that's all shop
class
oh I would do a shop class for sure oh
welding that'd be cool let's do well
yeah I would do that I would love it
I've actually welded before oh yeah when
I was a kid I made what
welded yeah
you like welding
all right
well well ding ding ding yeah yeah
I've welded
okay
well did you know I had sex with you